I wasn't planning on getting on here today.
In fact, I wasn't planning on getting dressed or going outside
or checking social media at all,
because I live in Charleston,
South Carolina, and every time I go outside today,
I see a let's go, Brandon T-shirt.
I see people reveling in Celebration.
And if you are like me, if you are a little blueberry in a cherry pie,
I wanted to come here and talk to you.
Charleston County voted blue,
and I think that's important.
It doesn't insulate us from what is going to be the red wave
or the majority of our friends and acquaintances and neighbors
who are celebrating Donald Trump's win.
However,
what it does keep is a good deal of our friends a little bit safer.
Um, our queer friends,
our trans friends, our women of color
who have tirelessly been working in this city for Equality and equity,
who have been carrying the banner of progressive values
for longer than we got on the train,
that's for sure. So today's gonna be a hard day.
It's gonna be hard week. It's gonna be really insufferable,
actually, up until January,
and then we can all collectively
hold our breath and see just how bad things are gonna get.
And while I sit here scared,
I also know that I occupy the privilege of being white,
of having a husband who doesn't seek to objectify
or subject me to a patriarchal
strong arm in my household.
I Have parents who are also Democrats,
which is very nice
because I don't have to excuse their votes.
And I know that I'm not done.
I know that the privileges that I occupy
mean that I am uniquely responsible
to both do the work and call in other people with equal privilege.
This may feel like two steps back,
and it is.
But you know what comes after that?
A giant leap forward. So
stay the course.